okay next question today
um does classical conservatism still
exist
this is an interesting question you know
when we talk about classical
conservatism in the united states
understand that the idea of conservatism
the roots of conservatism
go back actually to the french
revolution when you had
uh conservatives who were often
french intellectuals saying they wanted
to sort of
go back to the previous
uh way that france was organized
rather than the post-revolution france
when we say
classical conservatism in the united
states we're talking we're not talking
about what things were like pre-french
revolution what were
my understanding is that conservatism is
basically talking about sort of like the
1950s
where uh you still had um
there was less awareness of and
opposition
to not only sometimes systemic but
actually codified racism
um out and out sort of glorification of
patriarchy
um even crony capitalism in some ways
where it was more open where maybe now
crony capitalism is in some sense more
more hidden
that that's what i understand as
classical conservatism being in the
united states and sometimes it's
presented as
we want so-called family values based on
the bible
as well as a low very low regulation
environment which
goes towards that crony capitalism thing
that i said
uh the the basic reality is that as it
is the idea of conservatism is a form of
sleight of hand
where what they're really talking about
is
classical conservatism in many cases is
limiting
the structures of power to
privileged groups whether it's men over
women
whether it's business elites over
workers
whether it's so so it's not just a class
analysis it's not just a race analysis
that's fundamentally though what we mean
by classical conservatism
it exists today in some
vestiges among certain republicans it's
funny because
the people that trump calls rhinos
republicans in name only saying they're
not really
republicans anymore that's kind of where
more classical conservatism still exists
it's people sort of like mitt romney
it's people i mean i hate to say it
democratic senator joe manchin is kind
of like a 1950s
conservative in in some ways they are
ostracized by the republican party now
because the republican party is no
longer about
the types of issues people like mitt
romney care about even john mccain was
sort of beyond
what classical 1950s type conservatism
was
the republican party has become about
owning the libs about
rhetoric over substance um about
culture type issues divorced from actual
policy
even when you look at the more social
issues call
even calling them cultural issues
instead of socialism social issues is
interesting
before when it was you know gay marriage
abortion etc it linked to policy in more
of a direct way than a lot of these
culture issues when you talk to a lot of
these republicans who want to fight
against cancer culture and you say great
what's the solution
there's often really no policy attached
to it because they will quickly realize
the policy that would come to mind would
be outrageously authoritarian
and supposedly against many of their
stated values so
does classical conservatism still exist
in the united states
to some degree it's increasingly on the
outs
uh within the republican party
uh it does exist but it is not
predominantly
what the republican party today
has decided to be in favor of keep
sending your questions in
i will keep answering them on every
friday show
we've got a great bonus show for you
today to get instant access just become
a member
at joinpakman.com when you see me
sitting here at the microphone
oftentimes i'm wearing a shirt by a
company called
teddy stratford and i love these shirts
so much that i
asked teddy stratford to be a sponsor of
the show
and here's why i like their shirt so
much with other slim fit button-up
shirts
you often get this weird-looking gap
between the buttons where it looks kind
of stretched out but teddy stratford
actually has a patented zipper
that's hidden underneath the buttons
which secures the shirt against your
chest so it doesn't look
stretched and most importantly it just
provides a nicer looking fit overall
and the entire shirt is specially
designed to really improve the way your
upper body looks when you're wearing it
it also has a special type of collar
that prevents it from drooping down and
spreading open which is another
really great thing about these shirts
all of these things
really do a lot to make a big difference
when you're looking at a shirt
and that's why i like to wear teddy
stratford shirts on the show
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout